hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review i have another review for
you
um this time from same company with
product i tested
a week ago the gr research except that
it's not a speaker but
modification
to existing commercial speaker namely
the klipsch
rp600m
um
this is a you know classic uh modern i
would say clip speaker
the modification you can uh watch the
video the company has unfortunately
doesn't show you the actual pictures of
the uh uh
the uh upgrade and you gotta watch the
video and i'll let you go to their
website and do that um
the uh speaker was delivered to me with
the kit already installed by the custom
by the member and so i don't have a
picture of it either but again in the
video there's explanation there uh
on you know what was changed and why i
tested the stock rp 600m and i gave it
my worst rating possible the headless
panther
and the main reason is that it just has
this giant trough in frequency response
and i don't know about you but i don't
want this chunk of my music taken out of
everything i listened to this is a very
important part of uh you know music
spectrums i call it you know life of
music is in here and
you just can't do this what the
motivation was for the company i don't
know
um
i guess they thought having less energy
in here is a good thing and you know
people focus on the highs and the lows i
don't know maybe it was
you know created the what i call a
showroom sound
so at any rate um
we've got the new one and uh
uh you see the upgraded append the
rating excuse me let me take my
headphones off
so
again i apologize for not having the uh
kit for you to show but one thing i can
show you is that the it comes with these
uh
tube connectors that
accompanies as a superior to the
standard binding
post but
you know you have the option of
paralleling them in this case this thing
had dual bindings
and so the customer took advantage of
that by removing one of the binding
posts and then these two are wired
together so i only tested them with the
standard posts at some future
uh time i'll do analysis of of these
tube connectors i just didn't want to
compound this testing with that
okay
um
as always these measurements are
performed using uh quilipul uh near
field scanner which means that what
you're getting is uh
echo-free uh responsive speakers if it's
in a giant space with no walls and no
boundaries and so we get a very very
detailed view the format of this
review
naturally is different in that i'm going
to show everything in a b comparison so
you can see the old and new at the same
time
hopefully you have a high resolution
device and you can see this uh
these y format graphs um
if you don't just listen to my voice and
you can see at high level what's going
on anyway
so refreshing our memory again this is
the old stock rp 600m which by the way
has been upgraded to new version and
this is substantially fixed in the new
version by the company
um but you know we know it's clearly
wrong but one cool thing about it is
that if you look at these three graphs
the black line is the on axis response
to the just the one beam
this red one is entire sound field
around the speaker and the uh
blue one is sort of early reflections
and all three of them follow each other
which means that if you adjust the on
axis up these other three will follow
which is great that means equalization
is perfect and indeed i eq this speaker
and it completely transforms it from a
crappy speaker to a very nice speaker
and but obviously you can do the same
thing using crossover modifications and
indeed that's what we see in here
that hole is now filled in and we now
have a far flatter response still not
perfect we have some glitches here and
there but you know you're going to get
that in in many speakers and certainly
in budget speakers and their port
resonances and so forth that creep
through
we can diagnose what's going on a little
bit better by uh doing what is called
near field management measurements that
means i forget about what i said about
reflections and stuff we can stick the
microphone directly in front of the uh
the drivers and thereby
swamp the reflections and get more or
less what comes out of that one radiator
without taking apart the speaker and
separating those if you look at the
stock one
we see this hole in the crossover region
because these two are rolling off too
sharp and too far away from each other
if they move closer they'll you know
level out but they chose to have them
this way and chose them to be sharp if
you look at the modified version uh what
the company's done is instead of taking
those filters they were sharp is putting
more shallow filters and oftentimes that
causes problems in that you you you're
letting the woofer play far uh higher
frequencies than it would normally do
and you could have breakups and so forth
but in this case we get lucky in that
the driver seems to handle the woofer
seems to handle these higher frequencies
and i see no breakups in here so
and the benefit of that is that you need
less part uh this company sells you you
know if you will premium parts for these
kinds of
enhancements so every time he has to add
another element the price escalates
rapidly and so it's good news in this
case that you know he opted to have a
lower slope and lower slope work um this
speaker by the way is two and a half
pounds heavier than the stock one
literally when you pick it up you're
like whoa this is heavier i think the
other one's 16 pound the stock one and
this is 19 and a half pounder so if you
do the tap test on the side it feels
more solid it has this
no res as the company calls it uh
damping material that's been applied to
the inclusion and together with the
weight of the
enclosure it's it adds a lot more heft
to it by the way the knuckle test is
kind of useless it's a salesman
technique to sell you on more style
cabinets you really gotta measure to see
what resonances there are in the cabinet
i don't care how stout it is from
knuckle test you're not activating the
speaker with the knuckle reactivating
and with the drivers internally anyway
but you know bottom line is that it
actually is
far cleaner in what comes out of the
port so this uh i put a microphone next
to the port and we can see that in here
with the stock thing we have two clear
resonances that are probably created due
to the dimensions of the speaker you get
resonances basically sound goes to hits
one wild reverses comes back and adds to
itself so even though the port output is
reduced um you know about
but these residences often start
amplifying in this one those are nicely
suppressed far lower and at any rate
they were
you know we're kind of lucky that the
first one of these is where the woofer
is very strong but the second one in the
old design was right when wolfert
response was dropping but here um the
stronger response would dwarf these
things anyway what caused that whether
it was the no res or padding is
different or too much of it in there now
or it's moved around i can't tell you
know this is not a controlled study
we're just comparing you know one stock
that i bought speaker i bought a year
ago to come a member about this used and
applied these modifications
but the end result is what we see in
here and clearly uh credit needs to be
given that you know the speaker with a
mod has you know solves this big problem
in here and solves the crossover
so we now look at the early reflections
these are and i promise you guys but
i'll do a full in-depth uh video one day
of all these graphs and what they mean
and how to interpret them but for now um
just you know bear with me the original
one as i said what comes out of the
front on axes also comes out all the way
around so we get this massive trough in
the original one and that trough is now
filled a lot more so the deviation from
this trend line is far less so
not only is the sound directly hitting
you it's improved but also the one that
hits the wall so same as if i've done
equalization
put the two together and apply a little
bit of math we can predict
from these anechoic
measurements what sound you're likely to
get in your
room and we like to see a you know
sloping down line and a graph that you
know ideally matches at 100 but it never
almost does and this is as good a
compliance as you could expect from a
budget product
or even more expensive products uh here
we obviously have our
single hole in here otherwise the
compliance was excellent it's just this
one darn hole in here
so
as far as frequency response
improvements there's no doubt
objectively that we've made things
better with a gr mode
and then let's look at the distortion
this is tricky business because um
you have to you know to do a proper a b
in here after match levels but in the
stock one we have a big hole in there so
the output level is different than the
other one
so to compensate for that partially i'm
showing you just a relative output it
wouldn't make sense to show you the
absolute output when the two frequency
responses are different so we take the
ratio of distortion to the frequency
response then that ratio nulls out the
frequency response differences
um
at 86 db spl
there is a difference in here uh post
the base distortion list is there excuse
me in this class speaker
that there's this hump pronounced hump
which you can see better actually let's
go down to a 96 db uh this roundish hump
is kind of unusual why is there and you
know i didn't set out to figure out why
he's doing this but there's this broad
distortion in the woofer in here that
like a one one hump in here it appears
with the gr mod it appears that that
hump has been reduced uh in you know
because it sort of is there but it's
lower but then it's replaced with this
sharp peak in distortion whenever you
see the sharp peak in distortion it's
really not a distortion it's usually
resonance that means something's
amplifying and
what is the cause of that who knows um
could be the new parts are resonating
maybe the wiring resonating uh maybe you
know when you take it apart put it back
together uh now the the driver and the
cabinet are coupled differently and it
causes a resonance in here interestingly
enough the member that sent this to me
he thought he was hearing resonance
between two to 400 hertz i wanted to see
if the measurements would show it and
you know measurements do work and it
does show it in here but again i can't
put any blame on the design of the mod
itself uh why would it create a new
sharp resonance i don't know so i would
say in balance uh we have less
distortion with the mod in here uh
you know perceptually how you know
important that is that's complex
um
i uh
went ahead and ran the uh
cst water uh fall plot and this thing is
very tricky to get right and and do a
proper a b test again because of the
frequency response matter changes so
therefore what elongates in time also
changes
but you know doing my best to sort of
you know with thumb in the air matching
the two it appears that the mod with the
gr research has less resonances if you
look in here in this region there's less
extension in here than there is in here
and that this is caused by the way in
the frequency response peak in here
there's some kind of resonance in the uh
response uh oh by the way this probably
oh yeah this is the port resonances i
forgot so the port resonances add some
amplification in here but also their
resonances so they ring in time so yeah
that explains that sometimes good to
explain things to other people you
realize new stuff yourself
so anyway another way of finding
resonances is to look at the frequency
response i'm sorry the phase and
amplitude response and whenever you get
these little tiny little wiggles in it
it usually indicates there's a resonance
in there
where uh the impedance and and of the uh
the whole system changes but it changes
very slightly so yourself to pay
attention and we see one over here
that's pronounced and then we see you
know few finer ones over here uh whereas
we go with the modders just that first
one is there and the rest of them are
extremely clean in here you can see this
curve in here is clean this one is just
modulated so
okay now i'm going to give you some
bonus to people who read the text review
last night you guys watching a video and
i've now updated the text review um when
i post this i didn't have these older
measurements for the stock version of
these three directivity plots and i went
to recompute them this morning and
managed to get them updated so if we
look in here beam width is if we keep
the uh loudness constant how wide of a
shaft of sound comes at you and the
wider this is the more
room you have to sit and not in tonality
doesn't change
but also it means it'll hit the sidewise
side walls and come back and that can
have a diffused effect that can be
positive and it is research shows a
positive way to ninety percent of people
10 to 20 percent of people don't like
that they want to have more pinpoint
imaging uh even though in live music go
listen to a band it's never pinpoint you
know this comes out as a band or
orchestra it's just diffused haul sound
but anyway um so we measured this and
this red line is at 6 db so i've color
coded this thing and we see that with
the mod
this line is pretty constant and
controlled and then starts to narrow it
narrows because that twitter will start
to
beam and
and get smaller the unmodified version
is little worse even though that's just
the function of the physical
construction of the speaker which hasn't
been changed the reason is worse is
because it has that trough and output in
here so
if you add that back in as the mod does
then that makes it a little bit better
overall though this is a narrow
directivity speaker it's only
plus minus 50 degrees the most average
number i get is plus amount of 60
degrees so it's 10 degrees on each side
has been
uh chopped off that can increase
sensitivity and eclipse is known for
sensitivity and a more focused uh beam
but um
you know it's it's a
mostly a drawback but again 10 or 20 of
people like that and a lot more than
that think they want it but when you do
a blind test they they prefer the other
one so same graph we can look at it as a
heat map horizontally and you can see
that this is sort of sloping down like
this and this one sort of goes constant
for a while and then
uh you know lots of physics take over
and and it narrows down
uh vertically is a puzzle um because the
standard one has a very classic look to
it which is
you have a two drivers and they're not
coincident and so as you go up and down
it the timing changes you get
cancellations at certain frequencies and
that's where these two eyes are created
in here
and uh when you listen to the speaker
you don't want to this is the vertically
this would be right at the twitter
access vertically if you go up or down
you can fall in these two ditches in
here and usually that only gives you 10
or 20 degrees of room to go up and down
so that's what's important to put these
on stand and vertically have them almost
always point at your face or at your ear
and the more latitude then you have in
here the better it is if your stand is
too too slow just tip the speaker up and
that'll do the same thing um so this is
classic but here we have a very complex
radiation pattern in here so with the
crossover modification has been
performed the response of the two
drivers is very different the
overlapping more and it creates this you
know called the shredded response so the
little eyes are now
way
more
messed up in here which means that your
vertical
dispersion what hits the ceiling and
what hits the floor is becomes a lot
more different than the on-axis sound so
in theory that's more coloration um now
if you put a carpet on the floor like i
do a thick carpet by the way one or two
inches thick you want to have jack
carpet
on this thing a thin carpet will not
absorb down to you know one or two
thousand hertz um you wanted to have one
or two inches or put some padding under
if you do that that mitigates some of
this that means these reflections will
die off uh for the ceiling one having a
high ceiling helps or having an absorber
up there helps to kill these things
fortunately because the
the reflections that go up and down they
come at the same axis and the same
distance to our two ears they don't have
the spatial qualities that
horizontal reflections have to
horizontal reflections one comes from
the wall one comes from the speaker so
there's a distance between them and and
our ears pick them up differentially and
so there's perceptual improvement like i
said in in preference to that sound
vertically that doesn't happen and it's
in general it's very hard to uh
characterize the impact of vertical
reflections and how they are so um
you know so i'd say even though this
visually looks a lot worse in here
practical impact of it is not that much
um so
you know but objectively is worse
that way but subjectively we either
don't know or
we tend to not be i'm certainly i'm not
that's critical about that
so um for listening tests i um
started with
the stock speaker uh and to refresh my
memory of of what it sounded like and by
the way when i did the listening test i
didn't have any of these comparisons um
so i just knew that the trough was there
in a frequency response
but other than that i didn't know about
all the directivity different
differences and so forth and
oh before i go far uh let me scroll back
uh a very very important point here um
this correction came at a price if you
look over here the original one actually
has peaks that go above 91 db and
twitter is above 90 or 91db
you've lost about two and a half to
three db of of
of uh sensitivity with this mod so to
we we didn't just fill this hole in the
whole thing has been pulled down too at
the same time so
what this means is that you now need
more amplification power to get to the
same level and potentially now you're
driving the drivers harder
and excuse me and you could be
distorting
and i'll get to that in a second so i i
listened to the uh stock speaker and uh
you know a day in day out i listened to
the same clip and i'm testing headphones
that's some speakers next i'm testing
headphone speaker so i've got my stock
uh you know same tracks always by the
way reviews you want to ignore are the
ones that keep telling you i pulled up
this new album i just listened to it's
like forget about it you know listen to
the same bloody track all the time
because you're testing speakers i don't
want a music lesson from you or or what
this album is that listen to the same
bloody top yeah
track and i've listened five or ten
thousand times to these same tracks i
listened to the first five tracks i
listened to all the time in sequence and
as soon as i play him it's just in my
mind i have this picture of neutrality
and pleasantness and good sound that it
just was not there their eyes were
bright
and
usually that brightness with it
brings detail and other goodness but
it's
i guess i i don't know how described by
word but it just like when those tones
come when the vocals come they're all
recessed and it just doesn't sound right
so i didn't like it now and didn't like
it then so i put aside the speaker the
original 600m and plugged this in there
and it was just night and day difference
uh you know the sound was a lot more
full bodies a lot more
uh it just was uncanny and and you know
unmistakable uh yes the sighted test yes
i knew about the measurements but
you know you don't get to take out a
chunk out of one speaker in the
frequency response and then put it back
with another and say oh your side of the
test means nothing no
all of us will notice when you fill in a
massive dip in you know one to three
killers and
overall was was very very good sound the
highs were a little
bothersome and i did have to crank it up
a little bit more and when i crank it up
the bass gets distorted very unusual way
i can't describe it but it just gets uh
you know non-linear in an odd way but if
you stay below you know very loud levels
uh then it was fine and uh
on this thing but i was curious about
this high so i pulled out my revel 105
speaker that i keep on hand for
comparison tests and even though that's
an expensive speaker it's got a small
buffer and small cabinet than this and
it just was not as nice it's just bass
is so important to our perception that
even though reveals a much fancier
premium product it could not compete
with this with the mod um but i also
have a revelum 15 which is similar size
to this still a little smaller and boy
that one was a joy so i was listening to
it and i couldn't put my finger on what
why all of a sudden you know it sounded
so much well i mean the tonality was
perfect and it was just a great sounding
speaker i think it's a thousand dollars
uh list price you can get it discounted
um
but then i switched back to modded
600m and instantly the vocals and
everything shrunk right into the middle
of the cone
and the uh horn
and it was very dramatic and a proof of
the objective
data i shows you on a beam with that
this thing it's projecting a
narrower beam and
and therefore it's not sending much to
the side walls that then diffuse the
speaker uh listen to one speaker by the
way and this kind of spatial effects is
still quite clear because it's a
function of the sound
direct sound and reflected sound and
so there's no question that durvel and
that's their design philosophy is to
have uh uh you know wider uh uh
dispersion which then takes advantage of
the sidewall reflections to give you uh
this larger halo you know more lifelike
is what i call it on this thing um but
again there are 10 or 20 percent of
people that like this aspect when they
listen in stereo because the two then
can make a sound stage of the
instruments or more precisely position
but to me in listening mono clearly
you know that collapse and and even was
focused i i did not like that effect i
don't want to uh my eyes and ears pay
attention to where things are all of a
sudden you know i was enjoying this
female great tracks and and it was just
i was you know it was a big band playing
in front of me all of a sudden one woof
you know inside of a speaker so uh to me
the m15
was a superior speaker but if i were to
rate them the stock speaker was down the
hole
the
modified
rp600m is way up here and uh
the ravel uh m15 was here so it wasn't a
big gap and subjectively some people may
like that pinpoint imaging that this may
bring
on this thing so back to the dynamics um
uh first you have to have a powerful
lamp and i did had a purify uh amp by
audiophonics driving it and uh
and there's this cliff in the base that
gets distorted and you hit it a little
bit earlier with this because you are
crank it up more a very small difference
um and uh
on this thing so it's not a big concern
but if you have a puny 10 watt amp
you're using to drive this because you
thought glitches are very sensitive then
you might not want to make this mod but
if you were wise and bought a proper
amplifier with a lot more wattage than
you think you need right now you should
be fine
so where do we land uh this was an easy
test case the one flaw with the speaker
frequency response and that flaw was
directly a function of the crossover
design which like it was intentional and
so it was a classic classic sort of a
baseline test of can gr research improve
the frequency response and the answer is
undoubtedly yes done the job was
promised what you get
the measurements prove it and well there
are a lot of subtle differences here and
there that you know our analysis and
tools and measurements are very precise
gives us a lot of insight so we not only
learn about this mod but we also learn
about speakers in general
you know we can drill down but at high
level you pay 244 dollars and and you
get it improved speak much improved
speaker now the debate is you know
that plus the cost of the speaker should
you go buy a new speaker well there's a
version two of this out which means that
the version one is now being sold off
with very attractive prices and
and you can buy them used for much lower
price so
combined i think the owner is out only
500 or something like that for speakers
and uh and the mod and of course you
gotta put in the time tear the thing up
build a new crossover put it back
together um so but assuming that time is
free um
you know i'm not here to complain uh
from my point of view
you know i'll just apply the
equalization with one filter to one
second i can turn it on and off and i
can change it and and i didn't lose
sensitivity either but i understand some
people don't like to use eq and uh um
i'll talk about why that's a bad thing
in the future
but
if you're not inclined to want to do
that and you're ready to tear into a
speaker and buy the parts and make a
project out of it more power to you in
the text review if you want to go on asr
forum there are a lot of discussion
about pros and cons of this thing
okay hopefully you uh uh got something
out of this review beyond the uh just
the basics uh
again just you know thumbs up on the uh
upgrade kit from uh gr research uh for
this specific speaker okay see you in a
future video bye